brothers that's a thing in this game but
that's definitely at this game thing I
don't know there's a lot of things from
this game that cropped up and I have no
idea why it's cuz the game fun just
brings it out of you and our friendship
is so unique and funny except for Bob
Bob am i right wait jump in on this come
on get him no offense but you suck oh oh
I don't mean anything by this but do so
this is the new run oh yeah hmm uh-huh
burst rifle trying it machine pistol
machine way what alright who's not ready
it's Bob already I don't know I'm not
used to this I just happens I don't know
what yeah dude new new pods pod models
oh hell yeah sound and everything there
seat warmers in mine mine's got flat
panel displays on the I don't need to
it's automated
you know you guys know but God alright
try to actually focus but if if I just
start going crazy just someone stop
making please let me out of my cage this
is locked
oh you got to make noise to opener it
gonna be making them hard to opener the
med pack looks different
look it's bigger that's not it it's some
tape and some stuff on the frass really
shaking violently stop it's green in
here is it always been green in here Jax
but I see level is that what's happening
here
yeah cuz I got the rundown they were
like oh my god okay lights off weenies
alright blini guys look the locker has
stuff on different shelves
guys gotta come look at this holding
something here I got nothing okay I'm
breaking the lock stronger in this
update or did you do that for oh they
get up at the door that's interesting
I'm so sorry I didn't mean to another
range one at the end here do you need
some stuff yeah I got hurt on purpose
just so I can see within the new med
kits that's pro moves right there find
the fog repeller turbine and bring it to
the extractions relevant now they're not
going away
no God dang it
yeah she's on a swivel they didn't go
away
I healed owed myself to 91 I still got
95 and I've still got jam all over my
eyes is there a budding front wipe your
stupid face you scummy douche bag if you
fail a hack it now lets out a bleep Oh
like a like a level zero
oh that's not so high I love that what
everyone just agree to stop talking all
at once
oh no everyone zip tapping around hello
[Laughter]
guys I think all of your internet broke
all at the same time guys this game
shouldn't be called gtfo B should be
called STFU now you're being
condescending I was my honest that was
my true laughs it's [ __ ] dark what
the Frick yeah all I see is fog
this is darker than any level I've ever
seen watch your nut sacks boys I'm not
see it stop crackling I see Oh again
sounds like just the one yeah I went
left I went straight line yeah we went
left don't you know how to turn light on
and off good luck oh he's right in fun
of me
Oh your loft your character coughed if I
hover over you your infection is it 25%
wait if I heal you will that go away no
yeah no you're just infected Oh guys
kill me first
yeah you asked what the [ __ ] what's
happening we got it is we won infection
mechanic oh no oh no I'm at 81 and
slowly deteriorate put him down yeah
definitely that's the only option brick
to me
was it the fog I don't know I think
maybe because I just had taken your mask
off yet idiot wait let me oh yeah oh god
yeah no do not go in the dense fog I got
affective mark I'm Red Alert I'm
infected yeah
don't go in the dense is bad I'm pretty
sure this virus is just a hoax I'm just
gonna go keep going about my day oh yo
it's real it's real he's only 11 percent
in five yeah hold your breath you guys I
mean we all got masks on not very good
wake up every China knows you're here on
the ceiling is that gonna do sleepers
sleepers shrink
it's what we do about this week over my
mouth is up coughing it's pulsating it's
swelling Oh
what happen where's inside good put him
down
oh this is disgusting oh this is making
my whole head tingle I don't like this
you know oh that's the actual worst this
is really clever and so are you supposed
to shine your light on them or not makes
them shrivel up and not do explodes kids
it's a tool thing god I can't
stinky sleepy was my flashlight guys
[Laughter]
we're all in it now we're all a
liability oh no guys there's flashlights
gushers in here what are you flash like
boozers to the right there's like them
coughing me we should call them
flashlights like shine your light on the
flesh you call them flashlights
flashlights we should call it on it we
should call them flashlights guys at
mark everywhere everyone's already oh
don't wake them got it
oh that's where we made the mistake
earlier I was thinking another one right
there your assistance yes why aren't you
killing it because you have to wait a
minute okay well done is it clear that
butchers watch out for the goose why why
do we not wake the Doozers you say your
life
on the flashlight on the sleepers why is
this so complicated Josh man you said
shine light on it my character just said
a shite the weight you see that you see
the flashlight yes
I'm gonna call fall over this guy nice
oh okay there was one up here that I
also got that you got is neglected but
I'm a hero yeah sure I don't like this
who's that the highest infection rate
right now man I'm at 21% look just
because I like piccolo for Gohan blocked
the infectious blasts from you guys I
didn't know I was what are you talking
about piccolo to your you know you all
know exactly what I'm talking about
you took the blast for no reason I took
same as piccolo could have just moved
Gohan out of the way no I just decided
to take a face full of that yeah just
like me it's a perfect analogy huh
except your home is in the way you just
wanna run attacked it on your own I hate
all of this what's going on Shawn and
bomb exploded on some more yeah but see
9% so it's pretty AG listen you got a
look and then pay attention to what
you've seen where do we go how do we
know which fog is good and bad the dense
fog bags dense over here through all
them
I was just kiln [ __ ] oh man how do
we deal with this we should go up to our
mark wise yeah exactly
follow the leader more
now I'm going down fast but dudes I'm
guessing your infection determines how
much help you don't who did that
where did that come from coming up the
stairs it was you but where I don't see
where it was right there right there
oh damn it I'm not being an idiot right
now yeah yeah yeah hey how much
affection do we all have that's what I
thought
35 dude there's so many in this hallway
Oh God why is this even a thing there's
nothing up here Joe there's a guy
careful through it like geez let's just
go yeah security Oh
shotgun sentry go friend oh my god where
[ __ ] everywhere does circles first
Rack will take some getting used to
they're all coming down this hallway
well that's your is that one Oh God 9
percent 9 percent 9 percent you with the
recoil
oh wait pick me up grab my hand
don't mind the group Oh God ranged I got
your buddy Oh God
I'm not 85% infection I might be a
laborer 590 ups Bob you got it who's up
Bob is anyone still alive no you you got
a oh my guys actually Irish whoa I'm
down oh [ __ ] are you surprised the Green
Smoke the gross [ __ ] green things and
now Irish voice-acting are you saying
all Irish people are green [ __ ]
yes is that what you just said to me big
boy on my body I know he's coming for
his my turret would shoot him
hey go turret helping down white lights
and [ __ ] bleed no here come on
nice work team I'm American were you
downed by that before that happened oh
my god we didn't even scan for where the
turbine guys I got an orange key is that
good infection check I'm at 90 it caps
out at 90 I've discovered this okay and
it means you only duck it 10 Bursa no
this is a nightmare you come here guys
is it mark there's so many turbine oh I
got it holy
hey let's go home
I wasn't me oh I have to carry this I
can't take out my okay okay let's just
go let's just go let's just go
run run run run oh [ __ ] guys I think
you're gone the wrong way think you're
sick you're going the wrong way
there's a lot of shooting going on just
wait okay well nevermind alright I had
to reload oh my god what the hell can we
go shoot the things on the walls no no
yeah bleep I can't hammer them either
that sucked
okay this machine pistol not my favorite
thing the bird is okay but I'd rather
just be able to pick my shots we can't
do much worse than that
we can do way worse way more goo sirs
maybe we need a guinea pig one person
who's dedicating this guy say the
sentence out loud at a point in time
when everyone will hear it because Chad
is going on and on about it and they're
being idiots okay I go you're infected
the percent infection you have sets the
maximum health you can have so if you're
50% infective and you have 70 health you
will slowly lose health until you're at
50% health make sure I observed you
don't lose health at a certain percent
of infection it's not a man it's you get
that's how much house you get this time
three dudes you Ford five dudes you so
flashlights on there yeah run fast
brother
the rooms there's there's about seven
here but oh my god there's so many well
there's only four of us boys so just
start swinging to see what happens all
right I hate that plan I'll just get my
gun a let's do this man
let's have fun Bob what's wrong with you
Tom
that was me that was me
dodge dodge I'm the best dodging oh you
like the burst oh yeah if you just if
you pulled out in triple headshot it's a
one shot on all of those sleepers that's
nice I was actually pretty sick plus
look at that ass damn they kind of thick
though there yeah it kind of looks like
the things that squirt all over our
faces later yeah what that goo sure dude
though do you think it's just their
asses that are glued to the walls and
they're just like spraying us I don't
like this lore I don't like it
growin asses to be slapping up on you in
the chat can you tell us that's cannon
all right wait I mean we need to be
clear are they [ __ ] on the wall your
silence is agreement it is confirmed all
right who wants dinner
I'm not moving so if these [ __ ] wake
up I meant I'm I take no responsibility
okay okay okay okay there's four right
here and then one to the left
get low the one the project killed
without pissing off the ones on the
right yeah mark do a circle around left
I got some [ __ ] distance brah
jiggle wiggle
oh god this one over here I turned the
door get out get out get out I got two
of them oh god you're [ __ ] hurt shot
me Bob wait you put it there I could
shoot everybody get out like place don't
use don't thank you Bob it's okay I
forgive you Bob
you're welcome me I think this means
piss okay all right well okay stay angry
at Bob then you know let yourself be
brought down you gotta use idiots
American English when you hang out with
us bro yeah you know biscuits know
right oohs you know real American
English no prints on the Barbie very
tech nothing wrong you want against the
Irish people it's just you it's in zone
7 67 60 we're currently in zone 7 6 DC
sorry it's not it's own 763 my bad
lights off your left mark right inside
the door one to my left you see oh my
god what's he doing smashy or a squirty
smash Smasher today's question time yet
Smosh I'm just sayin flesh lights it's
really rolls is there anyone up there
tossed friend I'm getting know them just
hacking a locker I'm not seeing anything
else over oh I see one over here
I think he's alone the infection
infection
I have med kits up here and I'm also
carrying them so I don't I have to
refill but I feel like a disinfection
pack are probably important Bob you got
nothing in your sentry what this is
you're a person I look over you it's 62%
but I could view some of the tool refill
I guess you're gonna give them tool
refill so we can shoot you in the back
some more huh I mean it very clear yeah
yeah hear me very clear I hope we don't
encounter any flashlights this round I
just want to put that in the universe
and squirting it will manifest I am
willing it into the universe that will
manifest in my life I'm pretty sure
that's how this is designed yeah okay I
think I cleared out all the enemies back
- where's that door Lee leered out you
mean walk through an empty hallway
heroic 64 to 65 do you think 61 leads on
to 63 my psychic I mean one the math
logic checks out Wade comma comma comma
for the different areas they lead do you
think we should go through 761 I do
declare
alright here a mark da that's the same
exclaimed he declared or that opened
then the one the rest of us are at 761
mark you've led us here I will follow
you to the ends of the earth my tank you
thank you sir hmm
will you try steal credit wait what's
that fine toes there might be enemies
looking everywhere squirters there could
be squirters no no don't listen to the
fool that goes down you should go check
it out oh alright 7 263 is that door
over here there's so much area here I
just started thinking about squirters
and already I'm itchy all over and I
don't like it again did you manifest
some I manifested these itchiness is
right into myself where you don't like
things on the ceiling that are basically
transits that cover you an infection
juice way harder than the rest of us I
just thought of the
[Laughter]
walk it off manifested wait guys I'm
yeah I need a wall to do this by this
bit doesn't work I'll make it happen
again
oh my god you did it work for all join
me come on you had a Crouch the moment
you get off the moment yes perfect both
of us ah so damn it stay crouched am i
doing it yeah you're doing it you're
doing it bro that's as hard as when you
did it
let's fight it's my joke but you're
allowed to do it in with my permission
you know I also broken only the best of
us can do it yes to the skin Jude's in
my eye
you got it Oh you hadn't you've broken
Oh
okay we like this from now on you don't
get to come with us it's so weird that
you can't tell if you're doing it though
when you stop doing it Sean oh my god my
choice okay totally believe you dang it
gosh darn it yeah gotcha
that's really sick guys lights off
oh yeah right let's do this might be
that room then lights on well it's kind
of like a half hop situation that's kind
of like an ollie these it totally is the
room oh god I wish I had the long-range
flashlight that would be so good for it
I wonder I wonder if that like curse
blow to them or something
is this 63 this is 63 this is a day
Gousha room but they're not on the light
anymore so I also hear though I didn't
get you though it didn't get you oh I
didn't even see where it was I really
hate these enemies really itchy it
looked just like that that dance from
the commercials are they apparently not
in the same spots which is distressing
yeah Oh God look oh my god it looks like
they [ __ ] underside of a boat
barnacles that was my articles that's
what they're called barnacles I thought
of it thanks bro I just don't know the
range of them yeah I don't know how long
the flashlight keeps them off five six
seconds at the very most not very long
time America you want to get the guy you
know all gooshy oh my god
all right teamwork makes a dream work oh
I can't I can't goose them from here
[ __ ]
I I was even like flash lighting him
there was no stuff oh god take that one
for the day god I really pick a load
that one guys like [ __ ] 15 of them in
this room oh my god just [ __ ] screw it
turning turning get him get hurt
Oh big shooter shooter McGavin oh behind
us
one got passed how did that one go
through two of you to hit me that
[ __ ] we're chillin there we go down
with chillin chillin yeah we stop you
were great at that one how'd it go down
the stairs aiming for looking for stuff
I aimed that if it was a second too late
it didn't count when I'm standing here
toss oh come here come here
wait yes I can D in fact you feels like
at least some of these they gotta be on
you mark
let's did you see how many are in this
one hole look at the things cuz there's
things here there's so many things to
look at please help so it they do if you
go past them they take a time they take
some God or whatever
yeah I think we can sprint by so I think
if the hallway is safe wait that hallway
clear versus this hallway Shaun go go on
the right-hand side don't go down the
main hall mark there's boosters in here
yeah I'm aware yeah I see a motley
enough buddy no I'm far over here where
it's safe and less scary and you're
really in fact I am door I was wondering
if you could shoot them while the GU
shoes were out but that's a perk either
yeah it's I think it's just light do
they reload after they pop I imagine
they do oh where is that dude you're
dodging them like crazy
why just placing your turret turn your
flashlight off I don't like that at all
nonsense yeah there's two by the door
though so we gonna we got to get back in
that corner of America's I mean we got
to all be here first for a second anyway
[ __ ] yeah just shine your lights my
dudes shine your lights no no God that
turrets gonna [ __ ] me up I'm going for
it oh my god Wow
I apparently wasn't on it for some
reason even though I was oh there's one
in here
oh no yeah if I told you there's two
there's three oh [ __ ] this one oh my god
I swear I'm in this one here [ __ ] I
swear I've been in this one circle over
this whole time and it will not finish
this scam I think we all had to be in
that one it was a big circle up to it
one of the turrets shot me in the face
all right that's what you were saying ow
ow tie into the things talk I keep
forgetting that these things are
everywhere I'm down again I'll be rising
with like 0% health is a little rough
yeah that's tricky little bit down this
this hallway of infection is a nightmare
how do you deal with that that's
terrible it's hard that's rough
maybe seafoam will do something to him
[Music]
yeah I'll take seafoam because I'm bad
with the turret anyway we might need
like two seafoam errs probably probably
burst turrets would be better to just
for the break yeah little and the ring
yeah we should definitely film um we
wanted to see film two turrets sure what
if they're breakable if you freeze them
like that no probably not but it'd be
cool they were just a thing right that
does make them like shatter or whatever
we're experimenting everyone we're still
young enough to do that maybe we should
explore one of the other zones first
because there might be new items to help
us with this true true true interesting
interesting interesting very interesting
how does the machine pistol have more
bullets than the submachine gun that
doesn't make any sense
because it just vomits them in of every
direction maybe it's different ammo no
the machine pistol upon is like all guns
same bullets
everyone knows we've been Maori one of
the seven signs of our incoming
explosion you bound ash meow
hack the game and change the audio file
so every time something one of those
douchebags explodes it's just like guys
I have the power
OOP wait can we have that down a hallway
and murder them all at once yeah I'm
gonna list to see if there's like
doesn't show
wait there's multiple fog turbine
turbine one six one six one
why do we need a specific one they're
all the same to get rid of the specific
fog
damn it this one's in 762 so it's a
little closer than last time there's a
disinfection station yeah way disinfect
station seven two five it's in Zone
seven six four so if we find that that's
through this door down because the doors
open now no time to think only time kill
there's only these two one of the rights
and a really cool
well not a because you can see their ass
more Bob he didn't work tangling with
the music school in here wobble wobble
screech yeah I like that here and that
make music Bob I think what's clear I'm
just gonna run and jump around then so
you can open lock silently maybe we need
key black four eight four to get into
Zone two the disinfection zone that's
literally what that zones called it's in
zone seven six one seven six months
right here I have a disinfection pack by
the boy I'm gonna ammo myself other
lucky human it like a single-use lock
melter or is it like a three sixty sixty
percent I've got three of them it looks
like that's cool Bob are you bored yes
yes to make Siteman in your life then
can we play some freakin can we get some
bit for night fortnight yeah that's
going in lights blazing huh yeah bold
didn't hit off
simple pimple out oh my god oh behind us
where they can eat Jesus there's a bunch
jeez give him the old snasser you'll 1 2
well that was a lot more than gone
literally no worse I mean whoa whoa
where that came from
I might be sorry Jesus
sorry guys sorry sorry oh wait those are
things to work her special surprise am i
doing it again but there's no there's no
long-range flashlights though someone
else needs to fog repeller we should
replace the lock mouth no see I can get
it you know it does replace the lock
melter you funny it sounds cuz it's like
a utility and you only have one utility
slot what are you doing but flap I'm at
96% health I'm good for oh don't heal me
oh it's just I couldn't even read it
you're so wormy that they left the lock
melter okay as long as you remember
where you left it do you think the fog
repeller would work in that dense fog
down the steps well I was kind of
wondering explore do you think it'd work
in the fog up here
no no you'll find out it's a frog
repeller not a fog redistribute idiot
it's kind of blowing it up here where
did you talk I don't see good I eat my
words
I eat my words it didn't work in the fog
[Music]
it's marginally less effective when all
of you at once really you're doing it
right here and what I weren't even
saying words I was just making noise it
doesn't do anything
take that dweeb all right let me try I'm
gonna try yeah let me let me let me
that's not good he's so powerful
let me try on that one literally didn't
do a single thing to him oh I can't do
they just consume it listen disgusting
thing that I hate are you gonna do the
thing or what hey this is a hack lock
let me go get my melter I want to melt
it when you fail the hack it makes that
sound I've got these things covered
Shawn don't worry you're safe wait no so
mark the one that you see foamed over
here yeah he's not read not read I ran
yeah he's just chilling I'm not I'm not
shining light on him and he's just
chilling interesting there's
disinfection kits here by the way oh my
god you're right you're right so seafoam
does work it just doesn't have the right
animation for ya it needs to have some
sort of never mind
he woke back up and I had my hand off
the keyboard it is the good flashlight
seems to immediately scare away the a
the ace holes yeah what'd you do it from
way further away too which is very
important you can review that entire
hallway
yeah which we're gonna need get out of
here kit does anyone have a spot because
there's a I have two on me I think
there's a two that's a true use medpac
in there much I got the disinfection kit
so well I have a disinfection kit on me
well as well right now so what should we
need that or health well if we unlock
the disinfection zone then we won't need
kids ah maybe no one else is infected
right so no we chillin yeah I think I
melted this lock guys we can go in all
right I want to blast this this hallway
with the light of a thousand Sun I
changed my mind real quick on that one
I mean it's a whole line of them yeah
should we drop a turret and close the
door we could choose the door actually
Oh close the door and sorted through it
well cheater a cheater pipe you divine
let's do this okay are we doing what's
one are we doing we've died twice Jesus
Jesus oh man the developers are watching
oh god it's just gonna like stick may
have fixed the cheese they fixed it
hahaha that's what you guys get hang on
hang on let me try one more more more
cheese oh yeah that you got to get a
pixel perfect if you want it to know
they fixed it alright put it outside
then close the door alright I'll do that
that doesn't sound very fun or like
exploiting the game in any way that's
fun no apparently that's fun now
doors opening flashlight off you a-hole
no I'm keeping us safe Ready Set close
the door door closing all right time to
start flashing get them turret what the
doors doing a heck and shaky man that
hurts really well you guys left what the
hell the frontlines all right well who's
medkit again yeah gives you some hells
now buncha cowards if you guys want to
use to to use as it opens up a slot I'm
good I'm 78 oh no my knee eight okay
anybody have like one use left they want
to touch me up with nope
you small I guess you guys suck
well no one has left you're the one with
the only med kit where was that one you
gonna use your eyeballs man did it get
me through the stairs I think it got me
through the stairs
I'm blinding them with the light of a
thousand suns don't worry about it
friends this'll definitely it's on the
other side of the rebar there well I
can't get us in we can't go that way
because there's fog we have to go under
the stairs
oh cool sticks tacks
thanks do you think that would work oh
that would be interesting that would be
interesting nope all right that's not
anything then I thought clothes stick
was big brain yeah yeah I did too seems
like seems like it would be big people
see foam was big brain well sea foam
seems to work
it does but just doesn't it prolongs how
long there and knocked out or whatever
yeah I mean I'm just gonna toss these
everywhere anyway Oh God
which one of them are on Oh God there
was everywhere oh wait there's a sea
foam grenade in here whoa oh [ __ ]
okay there's sleepies in here but
there's also a thing right here go get
this though there's to go we got a match
this is bad alright I'm gonna try and
hack these okay I got these [ __ ]
happens Oh free these guys can't hear
this [ __ ] it up it's too late didn't
hear it that's a tool refill and this is
black for 84
hey that's to the disinfection zone grab
that let's go see what that's all about
yeah let's check it out maybe there's a
turret light just put down a giant light
lamp a home depot work lamp that you
just plop yeah work light strewn all
about here why can't we use those yeah
and they're pretty cool-looking yeah
when you feel the hacking it sounds like
it's a silly let's yeah what's she doing
there mark I don't know the circle for
your hit e hammer turns small when you
look at them because I know it's so
tempting but it doesn't do anything yeah
stress
oh you made that sound and it's good to
[ __ ] bladders out there gentlemen ah
sound like a bull dog's mouth this alarm
yep say it's alarm yeah all right
Bob do you want to put it down and close
the door on the other side while our
doors to our right so you know like this
it's not the only place they can come
from yeah weird what are you doing yeah
Wade I'll see form this as well if we
have to
I'm a seafoam bobster dad or the seafoam
lasts a while right about 3 minutes yeah
if you go out there there's one door
that leads to both the doors we've
turned it we could see from that door
this door right here oh you have this
one that might be smooth this is where I
had my turn aim cuz that door leads to
both the doors that we currently have a
turret on oh okay alright wait back up
it's like cuz you you were you're
pointing it at the door and I don't know
what benefit that's gonna do either we
can slap each other's dicks all day
let's just do this should I keep that's
a great that's a great that's a good
don't put them both on this door there's
do avenues where they could wait what
are you talking about that's what about
we're what about all of the other way
from zone 61 that we just came from wall
pimples don't move one's a wave nah no
it's fine all right I'm gonna whatever
I'm foaming up this door does that
alright okay
there we go this is gonna be the easiest
door we've ever had lame-o's we're gonna
have to go down into the infection to do
these locks i turded it and closed it
it's not seafoam but yep they're all
there here
oh there's a lot of them oh I can't
shoot through the forklift I've got a
gun a security decide to go through the
[ __ ] monsters alright I got it
what who's hitting me Oh are there
invisible one footage this this guy
right here
no he wasn't he wasn't the one who was
hitting me my turrets doing stuff now
big lad coming sorry we got this it's
whatever easy the machine pistol really
doesn't do much
alright I'm uh I'm a sea foam all of
this the doesn't walk they're gonna stop
bombing well I'm glad I wasted my
seafoam ammo big fellow oh I've been
hearing him I can't see him anymore he's
out there he's always there
Ned Ned his head gone dodged you [ __ ] I
hit the other ones you have a oopsie
there John
I need diaper your boom boys a little
weird got a lot of kills I exist oh the
seafoam is on the door and I can't open
it disinfection station whoa you burnt
my shirts on the other side of the
seafoam door oh yeah okay that kind of
works disinfect I think it's all dented
in well I bet is it unlimited you sir
what's the deal I still have infection
we'll get in this see this thing stick
your face in it you're just gonna walk
in the room and oh yeah thank goodness
Oh gross no okay I'm not going
station in there we all here we have to
go into that area we do not have to go
into that area we go back get the
objective that we have that true
interesting yes repeller it'll clear
those areas out then we have another
[ __ ] objective in those no we get to
the extraction zone that's it we get it
we get extract well know I'm infected
guys
oh darn it
juicy over here developers there's this
paper maybe some normalization wrinkler
do we know what area of the fog things
in yes 76227 60 yeah yeah I have a
disinfection kid so I could probably get
rid of that you never know when you
might want to be handily disinfected
that's true it's true that's true it's
just a pact all your friends too much
noise noise noise like Minecraft saying
oh god it does know we have to do the
[ __ ] hard door that we can't get past
that Trudeau that true it word come out
of your mouth that one that one was in
that one literally was hidden why am I
going down this hallway I pointed this
twice are you some kind of dumb oh yeah
behind a present
can we see I've got seafoam but I don't
know save it we should just go down
there put it down the main hall yeah we
should just try this we know what we're
up against
I'm oh god the alarm goes off right away
okay I'm Sam I'm C Foreman yeah I'll see
you foam as well yeah I'm out okay we
all need to be in here first
oh god these these things saw yeah okay
hey seafoam you're supposed to actually
you know stop people yeah one right in
front of you Jax
Sean kill him I'm staying on my
flashlight so we don't die to infection
we still haven't done the security get
in the circle
okay okay okay I'll do this one okay
what are you gonna drop a bracket or
something oh there's the range one over
here big one by the door big one by the
door okay got the range one oh my god oh
my god [ __ ] me
okay small ones other side long hallway
don't forget the things guys so very
much like the things there's just two of
you circles I'm all out of ammo
okay dodge time twelve chasing him oh
god I think this might be the end all
right so like Jesus crate we would have
been fine circle right away we ended up
fighting for an extra like two minutes
yeah who was a circle I think I might
have been coming into no sorry okay so
seafoam is the [ __ ] way forward yeah
machine pistol is garbage learn that
yeah SMG might as well do that
just gonna go with the assault rifle I
think that's just the best go of things
all right now that we know see with the
pistol yeah we going for the
disinfection zone is not worth it I
don't think yeah it didn't really buy us
much except for wasting resources until
we had to do the same battle that would
have been really useful to go get
cleaned up yeah but that's true yeah
it's not a priority though yeah at that
point we might as well just run to the
extraction zone I think this one could
be done in I think this one in reality
is like a 15 minute 20-minute round yeah
I really hope that we actually get to
extract when we take that out yeah why
would you
I don't know all those dark foggy areas
just I have a bad feeling about him I
mean it's probably in a dark photic fog
good area I think the orange e is the
thing [ __ ] us up right now yeah that
room was terrible for that fight we
literally Romantics six Gaucher's yeah
all right but this one's da one I feel
it's me waters your waters yeah I would
not know if you're just making stuff up
I would have no idea percent lies you
know technically everything's made up
guys
true true so you speak the true true no
enemies looks pretty empty here
stuff in here what do you mean we're
getting stuff we're all working together
[Laughter]
6:3 appreciate my locks okay but Bob you
made it cool you made it cool I was wait
was innovative Oh sick nasty wait what
you doin just laying around
come on B so they did Oh a buds all
right help me three two one Cabo oh nice
that's perfect coordination I love it
what do you mean we're ready to go yeah
dude you get goop on your face for that
yeah yeah brothers those who goop
together
it's the goop in your eyes can't see
nothing there's a lot in here my brother
yeah what I thought you I thought you
just missed him he didn't explode from
now on the left
four on the right FYI
five on the left three on the right man
I'm just [ __ ] walking by dude it's
not even seeing them I don't even count
them it I got so much goop in my eyes I
don't even know what's up that's too
close apparently I've done everything
right I'm perfect home I got it handed
some health so stop with that
Jesus Christ there's enemies in here
good god man bastard it's not the talk
of a group brother over there that's not
how you goop it looks like so all wrong
oh we're doing guns blazing good plays
I'm in the thick of the goop yeah turns
out there are too many people that goop
over here okay I'm running oh god oh god
man whatever
I
why are there so many in here and it was
like still on right over there
gooping gooped I'm honestly a little bit
blown away that's a fantastic
reenactment yeah brother come here
brother I showed up with you well like a
cheer eyes whatever dude don't even
worry about his broad [ __ ] like you
just gave I hear that accident and
you're a completely different human
being like I don't know if California
Mark that is how you sound I hate to
break your [ __ ] lights more up thank
you who's just I was just I was
knee-deep in that role okay
oh yeah there's one you see okay I'm
gonna get to that far one I got that far
one okay I got this guy this person gent
like something like wrestling my name is
my name is buck the kids whatever man
literally just beat you but my name's
Britt my swoosh okay mess mess that up
but it's fine everything is good
scooping properly up there come on
spoilers get gift or just get off my
[ __ ] property
that had that voice but you're like a 47
year old grouchy you kids need to get
off my lawn I spent eight hours on
Sunday getting it pristine I moved an
inch of my screen went black happens to
the best of us it's sad ecstasy man too
much
tell her I'll whoa mm-hmm the shooter a
shooter Raider
I don't do about shooter Raiders oh my
god so much bombs it's a hard fight I
didn't see anyone else volunteering for
that Smasher me Mike you do it okay I'm
in hacking all day my fingers are sore
watch this Pro moves got it I don't know
a single siren didn't dude I'm the best
by the way I'm a certain guns have
different ranges on their flashpoint I
didn't hear the certain guns have
different ranges on their flashlights so
if you got an assault rifle it's range
on the flashlight is long certain ranges
and it just cut out anyone need health
by the way Oh God nuts just a dude
shining you can do it you can do it at
top of behind your Bob yeah I know
there's not a good place here cuz bob
has 30% infection it's just gonna go
right back down oh yeah don't do that
excellent point Wade well Oh God there
is
Oh too late guy there I'm sorry my eyes
just started watering so badly that I
literally couldn't see my computer
screen I'm sorry I can't see you okay
something just got in my eye or
something I literally can't see out of
my right eye
oh well go take care of that brick I'm
sure if I just touch it with my fingers
it'll fix it yeah that's it I washed my
hands yesterday
[Music]
every now and then I touch my face in a
in a video and everyone's like these are
supposed to be touching this race I'm
like I'm at home
yeah after you've washed your hands and
you're in your own house is not it's
different it's I wear contact lenses I
put them in just by slamming my face
into the the contact on the dirty
counter in mind seriously I get that
it's complicated and scary because it's
a pandemic but there are so many simple
things that people completely blow out
of proportion or don't understand the
point of blows my mind
it's retching your face in the comfort
of your own home with freshly clean
hands is not gonna give me coronavirus
I'm fine I really do need to like wash
my because it's antibacterial think I
broke it but that doesn't kill a virus
and so it works cuz it kills the fatty
layer around the protein there you go
that's it got a lip Oh phobic property
or something that's why you got to wash
your hands to literate I'm going to go
to the bathroom and wash my eye out
because I have tears right now my face
don't I go okay well he's gone finally
out face you know he's gone
you guys should bring drunk minecraft
lark does alcohol still kill you
gosh no I'm cured oddly enough I started
washing my hands it's all good yeah yeah
just hold your breath it'll be right
back yeah hello it's my toe stuck in
[Laughter]
right bud
this pandemics done endemic pandemic was
called bad and that's very different
it's not even in the same word usage yes
one of those demyx I know high school is
me demek you demek we all digging what
Oh juicy what happened to me I don't
know what happened to you you washed
your face right oh it's just the light
it's certainly worth it over there
listen yeah let's just do the dang thing
get the dang out of here nice way to FK
some wrong with your eyes yeah it's my
nose and I think I broke it
hey I'm gonna disinfect myself so I'm
not anymore nice yes yes good play yes
brother yes yeah clean okay so there's
any to break the door this time so this
this is our raw not bad yeah not bad not
bad not bad yeah there's three there's
three there's three so we do that and
then we this is our safe zone we're here
we are safe safe corner yes I must start
seafoam and there's seafoam all down
this end oh sorry I was about to cover
it all right juicy again all right let's
do it all right I'm ready
now everyone staying up damn look at the
progress on that something something
something something talk to touch my
butt yeah that's what I remember
yep I'll try and help you with the
lights mark thank you many thanks I
think you're not getting at marks - oh
god damn it going
go like going sorry about that all right
all right back it up Oh big one
everyone in big one by the door yep nice
nice what next
and old handled handled that was one
deep in there I'm gonna go for it gonna
have to go deep I'm going I'm going I'm
just gonna eat it I'm gonna eat it I'm
gonna I'm in getting this one
okay that's I've been the line of fire I
only got 30 percent infections yep not
yet [ __ ] pretty decently done Oh Frick
got hit there this thing kicks like a
mule
did we do it
good job genteel mom oh yeah okay who's
that disinfecting kits does anyone have
those nope I have med kits I don't know
if I'm gonna get my century back or not
I don't think that's worth it yeah
I think just leave it yeah just leave it
lets it looks crappy feelin like this
door shall we uh yeah lights off open
says me all this strange darkness okay
there's there are gue peas directly no
but God Almighty
Oh God well is he alone what's the deal
I hear one on the way god damn it okay
ow Jesus Christmas please please my
light is on you you got that way yeah
are we dealing with here where are they
there's two okay we're good okay Oh
my father's here covered my lights real
quick I'm gonna ping yeah I watch you
that was 18 he's five that I picked up
oh that's further in where was it why is
that over here still pinging again Oh am
I about to be blood
no I got you yeah I'm defending mark
someone else is gonna have to go yeah
763 area B is where it's this one we're
in it okay cool
notice it's through the store okay oh
that was me the one got a door we know
it's in this next room to the left now
so you don't need to keep hanging
anymore
okay you know where it is yeah its own
it's the left down here
it's really then let's let's go three
feet away let's just try and stealth it
because if we have to fight this whole
next room we're gonna be in in the bone
zone
yeah I'm pretty little ammo this does
bring a whole new element to the game it
really does terrifying I really need to
have like good 3d awareness where you
lose track of them so quickly okay
someone get the one that's on me okay
I'm going for this one
coming okay I can smack whenever okay
wait where's the other one oh I say I
could go for it okay three two one good
we're good we need to go it this way in
my direction should we come with you or
should we continue chilling over here
there's so many big balloons yeah and
there's two guys up here you hit this
one I'll hit that one ready I think it's
out a variable yeah careful you're light
sleepers over there okay it's clear up
here good job boys I'm so afraid to move
right now I'm one infection away from me
yeah you move I got I got these
pollsters are you clear yep let's go
okay alright alright
765 wherever that is 214 okay sings
making a lot of noise okay I can't do
anything with this in my hand so if we
find out when you draw we need to light
you I think we just get out of here you
go back the way we came or are we going
left I think left it looks left
definitely well you can get your turret
now oh this goes to seven succeeds I
still just don't want to go in that
hallway yeah [ __ ] scary yeah yeah
this is terrifying this is a way more
stressful than most of the first run
down I never got this infection I'm at
50 both Wade and I are both at 80
oh Christ yeah Jesus so bad then that's
why we weren't doing stuff because we
would have just died probably let's just
[ __ ] go yeah I think we're clear
other than the lights yeah don't be a
[ __ ] alarm Oh No is it really does it
leave two seven six five definitely
76262 is that even the right way maybe
maybe this is the one oh maybe that
thing will push away the big fog you
know the big fog zones that we had
before maybe that's what's gonna
actually push it away cuz it's working
so let's get out of here let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
let's go guys yeah you want to try to
guau no that was me that's me I'm 90%
infected now dammit we could get the
infection station
did anyone grab the key I have a key
yeah okay yeah let's maybe do that okay
we're out of the we're out of hell not
quite yet but yeah okay okay okay okay
oh wow yeah clears the road driving the
fog away oh hell yeah oh damn fancy oh
this is powerful we said it's a circle
we need to stay close to him oh wow
tightens up in the back there I mean you
can't get any more infected okay I I
believe oh no it tops out at 90
infection yeah well I might go I think
it might go up but it goes back down to
90 so nothing you're clear completely oh
I can't sprint with this thing oh yeah
we do have to go through the disinfect
that leads to 765 so we can get
disinfected
but we have to survive this encounter oh
wait this is an alarm door [ __ ]
oh this infection pack right here Bob
I've ping yeah I know
should we top ourselves off a little bit
doing it because we need to delve we
need to I have one use so we should you
three I mean so yeah we should disinfect
some people I guess you should use it
twice on yourself now do you twice let's
all do each other guys all right
fast circles boys fast circles big dicks
gentlemen so we do oh they're coming
from that way interesting we don't have
covered foam that little door the left
either y-yeah nice good call good call
could get these circles circles done the
circles done next set going towards the
left door it's all right it's all right
panic is the enemy chaos is your friend
okay I'm on a circle
I hear you yes they are got that last
one last one last one oh boy that's a
long one okay come on game under it
oh there are multiple we got it we got
it we got it and bam done okay here they
come back behind the turret I'll back up
to the door
backing up slowly reading whoo
yeah good Sara Lee oh there we go
there's a big boy right
maybe I don't that's it we got no we're
good we're good oh my god wow my turret
this is the thingy right disinfect
really loudly it works better if it's
loud
good guys chill chill chill chill chill
chill well and that's low there's a
sleeper in here I'm talking about it I
didn't I all they're just in three
sleepers Sean I'm ready let's do it
sure this is help there's a watch out I
got hit by it when I do that before I
lose all this health I have yeah get it
man one point at a time Jesus
oh but everyone can use it at once okay
robot I love a robot it's something The
Grudge oh my god I'm clean baby clean
could use some health but completely
disinfected
I'm sure we'll be fine
[Music]
okay as the furthest we've gotten let's
not [ __ ] it up now
okay just there's just one more dude we
said above use it above you is it above
me you're right good call got it cool
I'll watch the ceiling saw watch the
ceiling
I'm coming with a fogger just to make
sure Oshin
the thing is so loud I don't think we
don't need to go that way we can just go
I'm just clearing out just for the sake
of whoa my god
Whiteley scream why do they scream I
scream whose oh it's my it was my
flashlight I'm an idiot it's all good
it's all good let's just go to the
extract let's get yeah screw that way
that that sucks mark let's leave socks
over there
[Music]
like in this are we oh god I can deal
with sneaking I don't want to deal with
[ __ ] sits down here there's this
there are this there are this oh wow
okay I'll take one kill myself once
okay I'm gonna heal Wade thank you so
I'm a forty five forty thirty eight so
Jack gets one and markets one okay and
then how many do we have after that I
don't know I'm doing Jack I think we're
good
all right so we're all almost fifty yeah
yeah yeah baby all right all right
oh god it's okay it's okay we gonna
write down here I don't know no no
oh here 765 this one goes to 765 that's
what we need right yep
if you're gonna if you're gonna keep
your light on just keep them up yeah
keep up good call good call
okay slow down okay I was stuck on
Wade's thick ass its thickness it is
nice I hear that clickers sort of right
yeah to the right okay I'm gonna get him
I'm gonna get her momma get him okay man
it's a good thing we're so good at
teamwork okay I think maybe we should be
like mark leads and you follow mark and
wait and I'd stay inside so what we have
like a train situation yeah I'll do the
good boy okay we got ice here three yo
guys just started apparently nice okay
okay I think of the heavy fog is helping
us
nightmare of sources and 64 e the one
we're in right getting this one yeah I
think so doing this [ __ ] haunting got
another one
this is 765 no no one more one more
okay damn it I'm gonna do stairs I don't
hear anything
they can't throw it on that much [ __ ] at
us in the middle of this where's that
log oh do not be alarm it's alarmed no
serious LARM day I'm gonna put on the
fogger like right here okay we should
take the fogger back to the door and put
our sentries down maybe yeah centrosome
it's turning off its turning off its
turning off its turning off oh no how
are we gonna manage the circles if one
person has to go with the thing I think
it's just like we'll just have to get
infected and hope it's only one or two
rounds
alright ladies and gentlemen this is a
big momma
I'm just hoping it's gonna be a light
one my shotgun it's alright oh yeah oh
it's a big one it's two big ones okay
yeah everyone's good right okay yeah
we're good yep yeah let me get some more
over here let's come over here this way
yep okay they're hidden that that's good
okay all right just one more okay they
broke here here and go in here where are
they I don't see well there's one more
back well everything guns on us in the
fog in the Fox
I'm down but don't worry just set this
down oh there we go get the circles
don't worry about me why'd you guys
behind you at the door oh my god that's
so brutal wait oh it's not even
finishing huh we're all down but it's
not ending 39 meters away from extract
that hurts that's so hard my god yeah
that's tough
that is tough but that was fun I like it
the new things they put in it brings
some balance to it I don't think that's
so noble anymore my god
[Music]